before the calamity before Ganondorf
before all the monsters in the world of
Hyrule we know of today there was the
one that started at all the one whose
malicious hatred of the goddesses would
burn brightly for generations to come
the only name we know this man by is
demise the demon came who is he why does
he hate the goddesses with such passion
and how was he able to curse the world
for all eternity in this collaboration
episode featuring a special appearance
we're gonna delve into the history plot
legacy and more of the demon behind all
the bloodshed the demon behind The
Legend of Zelda
hey guys messin gente ban it here and
we're gonna jump right into the episode
in just a second but first I'm gonna
introduce my friend the Hyrule gaming
he's got an awesome zelda channel that's
growing really rapidly and was kind
enough to help out with this video I
also helped out with a video over on his
channel as well if you'd like to check
it out after this episode I'll have
links to his channel and our other
collab that's already uploaded in the
description and at the end of the video
so please be sure to stay tuned until
the end also there may be another
surprise waiting for you at the end so
you're definitely gonna want to stay
tuned hey guys hyrule gamer here i'd
like to quickly thank fan that for
letting me join in on this video if you
don't know me already I make all sorts
of Zelda videos covering discussions
theories and all sorts of other Zelda
related content be sure to go and check
me out after this video
long ago in the ancient kingdom of
Hyrule or what was known at this point
in time as the surface there was peace
the surface was a beautiful place but
was due for one hell of a history to
come the origin and background of demise
lays within the history of this once
peaceful land the story goes that during
the era of the goddess hylia a multitude
of demons rose from the crusted layers
of the air on a heated pursuit for the
treasured relic known as the Triforce
this gray army of demons invading the
land was led to we know as the demon
king demise we were told in the intro to
Skyward Sword that some sort of great
battle took place between hialeah and
the demon king the battle ultimately
resulted in the deaths of many innocent
hylians and resulted in hialeah
gathering the survivors of this battle
along with the Triforce and seeking
refuge within the sky but the battle
didn't end there once I lay ahead guard
people and the Triforce to safety up in
the sky she thankfully managed to seal
the demon king away and then separate
the once peaceful land known as the
surface and the newly formed Skyloft
with a thick barrier of clouds leaving
demise sealed away down on the surface
how did this all happen
well the demon king demise was created
with a born hatred and greed hi Leah had
everything that's something he wanted
and would do anything to acquire the
almighty Triforce as this would allow
him to rule the land and if that
happened at this time there would have
never been a kingdom of Hyrule that went
on for thousands of years it would have
never happened in the events of Skyward
Sword the only Zelda title which gives
the players screamed time with demise
himself we begin the game with our
protagonist link having strange visions
haunting his dreams in his dreams he
sees a large black monster that vaguely
resembles an avocado with teeth once
linked awakens the monster is forgotten
about and the normal events of the game
continue on but eventually what is
revealed to us is that the monster from
Link's dreams is none other than the
ancient imprisoned evil being referred
to as simply
the imprisoned as the game progresses
link encounters another demon lord named
gear Hakeem who reveals that his entire
plot centers around the kidnapping of
Zelda so that she may be absorbed by the
imprisoned thus transforming the monster
into its true original form none other
than demise himself link beats back the
imprisons escape attempts several times
throughout the game and his quest to
save Zelda but ultimately he rahim is
successful in outwitting the hero and
his companions he successfully captures
Zelda and resurrects demise from his
imprisoned form demise having finally
been freed from his avocado shackles
wants to return to his original quest of
killing the goddesses but in his way he
finds one simple mortal being who would
dare to challenge his bloodthirsty
conquest link demise is deeply impressed
by Link's courage and challenges the
hero to a duel after a hard-fought
battle link comes out victorious driving
the master sword through the torso of
demise and sealing him away within the
sword before demise meets his demise he
swears to link that a curse will follow
the blood of the goddess and the spirit
of the hero forever dooming the
generations to come of Zelda's and links
to defend the light against demises
malicious darkness
what does demise mean to the Legend of
Zelda series well believe it or not he
is actually one of the most important
characters and not just Skyward Sword
but every single Zelda game the
significance of demise is undeniably one
of the most important in history to the
rich in lore series known as The Legend
of Zelda why is this you may ask well as
bandit previously mentioned demise lead
a curse upon the land to pursue the one
with the blood of the goddess and the
spirit of the hero along with world
domination
now why is that significant well the
customized laid upon the land of Hyrule
and the future generations of the
kingdom is why we have the events of
almost every single Zelda game demises
cars result in the tragic and malicious
attacks from Ganondorf we see an ocarina
of time and Twilight Princess it
resulted in the great
me too arguably the most devastating
attack from Ganon all of these attacks
are due to demises cars the repeat
formula of Lincoln Zelda having to face
a gray evil time and time again is the
previously-mentioned cycle of rebirth a
never-ending curse that plagues the land
of Hyrule and every single incarnation
of Lincoln Zelda essentially without
demises curse we wouldn't have the
events of the majority of the Zelda
series demise is a very significant
character to this series so what now
with demise defeated can be heroes of
Hyrule ever rest easy
as previously mentioned demises curse is
eternal it is widely believed that
demise is behind every major enemy of
the Legend of Zelda franchise and
chances are demise is most likely behind
the reanimation of Ganondorf we see in
the sequel to breath of the wild is
there no end to his rage is there no
stop to his malice or his demise a part
of the goddesses plan for balance to the
universe maybe in the sequel to breath
of the wild these questions will be
finally answered after all these years
did you enjoy this episode which demon
should be covered next let me know in
the comments below also huge thanks to
hyrule gamer for helping out with this
episode if you've got a second please
check out his channel and our other
collaboration video which is live over
there right now I have two more really
big thank yous to give out to my two
first patreon supporters Kitson hornet
and our lee quinn are my two first
supporters on patreon so guys thank you
so so much here is your video shoutout I
hope you know how much this means to me
if anybody watching is interested in
supporting me on patreon and is
interested what the rewards are for the
different tears feel free to check it
out over on patreon comm I'll have the
link in the description and in a comment
below also I promised you a surprise if
you stay till the end so here it is tada
from the very talented artist de
Cavendish time apologies if I butchered
the pronunciation by the way comes my
first piece of original fan art this
will always be cherished to me going
forward and I wanted to feature it here
so that everyone
and see their creation on another note
if you're interested in joining our
discord server or supporting the channel
I have links to those both in the
description below be sure to like this
video and subscribe for much more cell 2
content to come have a great rest of
your day peace
[Music]